ces images ont été tournées en caméra
cachée dans ce parc de mumbai de jeunes
couples non mariés se cachent de leurs
proches
simplement pour vivre leur amour
j'ai vite compris que faire un sujet sur
l'amour avant le mariage en inde
ça n'allait pas être facile et est en
bois senelec
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue dans un mariage un dire un
nombre incalculable d'invités avec tout
le luxe et le faste qu'on peut
s'autoriser
le mariage c'est l'événement le plus
important dans la vie d'un indien
[Musique]
un moment fondateur est sacré qui est
avant tout l'union de deux familles
[Musique]
[Rires]
si déjà les renac se connaissent depuis
à peine deux mois mais ils se marieront
dans quelques jours un mariage arrangé
les fiancés de 26 ans appartiennent à la
même caste s'ils font la paire sur
papier ils ne savent pas encore c'est
l'amour sera au rendez vous pour réussir
l'alliance parfaite leurs proches sont
passés par un courtier
un arrangeur de mariage comme harry
soumitra un décès d'abord par des hordes
d'ados cta is looking like docteur
d'optelec grid est mort à bonne école
sur ces cv ultra détaillés on retrouve
des informations physiques comme la
taille le poids la couleur de peau le
groupe sanguin on apprend aussi la
salers la religion ou encore si la
personne est végétarien
la famille est aussi décrite ses valeurs
le métier des parents des frères et des
soeurs et ses retours dans le parc où se
cachent les couples
c'est aujourd'hui le premier
anniversaire de rencontrera orléans jazz
mais le couple n'a pas le coeur à la
fête
il est tourmenté par une russe qu'il
prépare une femme et mes patins il est
léger super mario
l'animal
[Rires]
tiraillé entre tradition et modernité
les jeunes indiens revendiquent de plus
en plus des mariages d'amour
malgré tout les unions arrangées sont
encore largement majoritaires en inde
il est acquis que l'amour c'est quelque
chose qui se développe
après le mariage mais cette fois sans
avoir à se cacher
[Musique]